Is ecology on the left?
Certainly not.
The electric car is the future.
The electric car is a.
New wind turbines must be built in Europe.
When people accept them,
ecotheorism is a reality,
right?
I often agree with Jean- Jean-.
Sometimes I agree with Jean-.
I am more right than left.
I am totally centrist.
The climate crisis will be solved by innovation
technology
than very partially.
The right-wing parts are not green enough,
That's for sure.
Farmers are right to revolt
100%.
It takes 1
world government
to solve the problem of ecology,
no,
it takes 1 global agreement
of peoples and rulers.
Yannick Jado was the best candidate for the
Method for ecology.
Yes,
the world would be better if everyone was vegetarian.
but you shouldn't be extremist.
Uh.
So we need to reduce meat consumption,
we must limit our air travel
4 times in his life,
we must limit our air travel.
The cops are good for something,
It is used to do pedagogy.
I am in favor of 1 return from prison ?
Certainly not.
Ha ha ha ha.
Hull 28 is a very important success,
no?
This is a major failure